hey guys today I'm going to show you how
to permanently get rid of your acne you
ready for this are you sitting down
good take notes alright the anatomy of a
zit okay let's talk about what's really
going on we have a little bump right
here it could be filled with fluid or
pots or not there's usually redness
involved it's using the face the back it
could be anywhere on the body but we
have several pieces to this puzzle
number one we usually have higher
amounts of androgens androgen is a male
hormone during puberty you have the
spike of androgens and what happens is
like you get this overproduction of
sweat glands and those are called
sebaceous glands you don't need to know
that but they're just the sweat glands
start becoming enlarged because of this
woman right here and there's other
causes to this well we'll get to in a
little bit but the point is that when it
increases the sweat glands start to
enlarge and then you get more oil
production and that oil is called sebum
and it's there to lubricate the skin to
help regulate temperature to prevent the
skin from drying out and there's other
functions as well now not only do you
get this enlargement of this gland you
also get a lot of turnover with cells
and you start getting more dead skin
cells in the area and they can clog
pores and they can get infected and they
can create blackheads and whiteheads so
you have a lot of things happening due
to this hormone right here okay and of
course as a by-product you get
inflammation that's why it's red and
tender now it just so happens there's a
certain microbe a bacteria that lives in
your skin that eats this oil okay so who
you are you just provided more food for
this microbe it starts developing an
overgrowth okay
and this overgrowth of bacteria produces
as a side effect something called
proprio neck acid and it's the proprio
attak acid that gives the body odor and
it just so happens that there's higher
amounts of this acid in Swiss cheese
okay so we basically provide food for
more bacteria which creates more
inflammation
and this is why a lot of people when
they go to the doctor get an antibiotic
for their skin conditions but that's
only addressing the tip of the iceberg
just a matter of time before it either
comes back or you start developing
antibiotic resistance and now we have a
big problem so it's not the best
long-term strategy all right so then we
have vitamin A have you ever heard of
accutane and I'm pretty sure it's been
taken off the market in 2009 because
there's a lot of side effects from that
synthetic version of vitamin A but it
did help people with certain types of
acne right
why because vitamin A is essential in
keeping the sweat gland or the sebaceous
gland in check so it doesn't become too
big so it really helps to normalize
these glands and the production of oil
and it does a lot of other things with
the skin too it keeps it healthy it
keeps it soft it's intimately involved
in a lot of functions with your skin and
of course vitamin E as well it's also
important in anti scarring so if you're
a deficient in vitamin E a lot of times
you'll get pock marks and scarring after
the acne and it so happens that vitamin
E is very very important in producing a
balanced hormonal profile as well so we
have high androgens we have bacteria
with a vitamin A deficiency vitamin E
deficiency inflammation and scarring
okay
so what can we do about this okay number
one how do we lower the energons well
guess what will trigger antigens insulin
I don't know if you ever heard of the
condition called PCOS polycystic ovarian
syndrome well that's the situation where
you get acne facial hair you're female
and you get a deeper voice because your
antigens are increased and that comes
from insulin okay so the solution for
that and to read keep antigen in check
is to make sure insulin is normalized
and how do you do that you guessed it
you get on a healthy ketogenic diet go
low carb that will greatly help to
balance this right here so lower insulin
and lower stress stress can activate
antigens okay number two how do we do
with the bacterium bacteria live on
sugar well guess what if you're on the
keto plan you're cutting down sugars so
that's going to actually starve off the
bacterium and I'd also recommend a
actual antibiotic which has no side
effects rosemary and clove okay needs to
our excellent natural antibacterial
herbs okay now next one is vitamin A how
do we get that start consuming more egg
yolks some cod liver well don't go on a
low-fat diet okay that's not going to
help you we cut down the carbs we
increase the fat but we make sure it's
high quality egg yolks cod liver oil
that gives you the vitamin A to really
help this gland from getting out of
control
fourth thing what do we do for
inflammation what we do is we do in a
minute fasting the combination of
healthy keto and in a minute fasting
with the cod liver oil the egg yolks and
this right here is just going to really
help you in a big way when you do nomina
fasting you drop inflammation everywhere
in the body really quick and I have a
video down below if you're new to this
channel that will teach you step-by-step
how to do it correctly and you're going
to see some serious improvement not just
with your skin but with your health in
general alright guys thanks for watching
hey guys real quick I have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you just go to dr.
Berg comm it's right on the front page I
put a link down below download it it's
free check it out